thank you very much thank you for the
Dean's kind introduction and it's a
pleasure to be here I graduate here in
1994 20 years ago and was the only
person from my class who was crazy
enough to go straight to Beijing from
Bay Area understand more than half my
class stayed in the Bay Area because
this is such a beautiful place just walk
out and look at the Sun and you know and
at that point like the Dean was saying I
was thinking it was only going to be
there for two three years and 20 years
later I'm still there and I come back in
the 20-year reunion and came to realize
I'm not the only person in the class
with more white hair than I when I was
here but in any case over this 20 years
I've been involved with five early-stage
startup companies - as executive
management of consumer Internet
companies three as an early stage
investor for mostly entertainment media
companies so what I want to do in the
next 30 minutes or so is really to share
with you the experience I've had in the
last 20 years of Chinese internet how I
believe that actually the market
differences is driving innovation in
this market as well as some trends I see
going forward as we move to the next
phase of it the Chinese internet so this
is what we want to talk about right now
so first of all some background and
history 1994 the first year the first
64k line was pulled from China to the
Wawa web around May of actually 1994 at
that point they're companies like Asia
info and Yi Highway which is Chinese for
information highway I remember when I
first landed back in Beijing I was still
using MCI mail and comfy surf if you
still remember those names for email and
basic Internet services and my
classmates went to Netscape and Cisco
and Jeff's goal Class of 95 I went to
eBay to become the president of the
company here in the valley but back in
China
there weren't any consumer
websites so at that point it really was
infrastructure development and very very
early days so it wasn't until 1997 to 98
this is really the first generation of
consumer Internet companies in China
back then I was an early stage investor
and we actually worked with a lot of the
US media companies here like Steve Davis
or times-mirror
to set up operation that publishes
Chinese editions of books and magazines
in China I was like PC or PC computing
ones that you may and popular science
ones that you may be familiar with and
back in 1997 we'll also start a website
called ZDNet China which became CNET
which was actually with China byte of
News Corp one of the earliest consumer
internet websites and of course in 1998
symbolized by the three portals Sina
actually was founded by a merger of Sina
net which was founded by three Stanford
grads and it only thought which is a
local Chinese PBS company as well as so
who and Nettie's were the three portals
I personally also spent six years at
Soho and during this period is really
the first really the phase of consumer
Internet companies in China at that
point the market differences were vast
in terms of time gap there was clearly a
time gap between what's happening in the
valley and what was happening in China I
would say about two three years time gap
of the incident development at that
point in time but as we fast-forward as
I'll show you that will closely the gap
will be closed very very quickly so at
that point a lot of people there was a
term that a lot of people use was copied
China whether it was the product models
or the business models whether you call
Yahoo or whether you talk about eBay
all those Silicon Valley models were
very quickly over time replicated around
China by local entrepreneurs started
with US models mostly and but as the
incident blossomed in Asia what you also
see is Korean models and Japanese models
really emerging in light of online
James Mobile value-added services and
internet value-added services these are
different sectors where Korean and
Japanese models because of the mobile
internet and the advent of games became
kind of the the benchmarks for a lot of
Chinese Internet companies so for the
first generation of consumer Internet
companies that's really the backdrop now
but at the same time this period all the
way back 20 years ago to this day if you
look at all the major categories of
Chinese internet actually they're
symbolized by local entrepreneurial
companies in all sectors really and then
what these companies have done is really
localized the product as well as the
business models we talked about these
Silicon Valley or Korean or Japanese
models but the first thing in terms of a
key success factor is how do you
localize by adaptation if you don't
adapt a straight model from the US or
Korea and Japan we fail in China because
the market conditions are so vastly
different but these entrepreneurs over
the last 20 years have created about
over 50 I would say now kind of listed
new media companies across stock
exchanges around the world so this is
really a first face so fast forward when
we have this first period of instant in
China we're still there is a time lapse
and people called the a copy to China
model although with founded by
entrepreneurs if you fast-forward to
2005 and 2006 that's really the second
really inflection point the advent of
broadband internet in China now I'm in
the space of online video and besides
the really the advent of broadband video
one phenomenon I saw was a very famous
program called Supergirl that's very
similar I think to American Idol here in
the US and it was the top show of that
year and really was the first show where
through Pisa a PC instead of viral
popularity as well as using
SMS to the phone to vote for these
grassroot singers through a television
interaction it really was the first age
of multi-screen entertainment and it was
that in that backdrop that we decided
star our company which was called one
verge and I'll tell a little bit about
the background of that so this is
Chinese for those who can read it has
all kinds of different meanings but it's
converged into one like I said our
company when was founded it was called
one verge and it was founded actually is
it very much a Stanford and some send a
whole role model it was a search fund
because we didn't know what we were
gonna do so with a coal team of people
some startup capital and we spent about
six half a year really looking in the
whole space the video and deciding what
to do but the trend was people talked
about converging for decades or long
periods of time but we saw that
technology and content trends were
starting to converge around 2005 and
2006 around the world as well as in
China and another story that I think
that being would appreciate is 1992 when
I first came to Stanford I was fortunate
to have the Dean as my in my first
semester doing strategy or my professor
and I don't know whether they remember
the first class the first class was
actually about convergence the whole
idea of strategic alignment and
strategic consistency why it's important
for a company to have the vision as well
as the mission in terms of direction
everything around it needs to be
consistent so the whole idea of
convergence and converge into one was
something that really stuck with me
and in Chinese really interesting
convergence for ping Chloe sam'l for
those who understand Chinese
Chloe is actually one Verge and it's
multi screens and multi networks
converging into one and that really was
the concept of the company but most
people actually recognize us with our
consumer internet brands which is yoku
and to doll and to know as a website
that was the second largest video
website that we've merged with
in 2012 so this is kind of the
background of how our company was
founded but during that period and as
you see that the gap I was talked about
in the first generation of consumer
internet have fundamentally changed by
the time we head to 2005 and 2006 you
see a lot of the product and business
models and the innovation are happening
in many ways in parallel after about ten
years to eleven years of Intel internet
development around the world and what
are you seeing is these kinds of
innovation as partially driven by a lot
of market differences well let me give
you some examples we're in the space of
online video when we first started
actually to dole as a website was
founded before YouTube was founded that
was roughly around the same time so you
can see that in a space when all these
parameters in broadband video in terms
of Flash technology all these different
parameters get to a inflection point
entrepreneurs around the world are
starting this companies almost around
the same time and for you you're cool
for example there are some clear market
differences when we will look at the
YouTube model for example which is
basically user generated video in China
I remember when I was here the show
caught America's Funniest Home Videos
was actually very very popular and so DV
penetration as well as usage is actually
very common here in the US but that's
not the case in China if you go to China
when we started the company
there are DV penetration was really no
there there's no such show as China's
final Funniest Home Videos and so the
whole idea of DB history and culture
very small so we do COO for example
started as a pure UGC as a YouTube model
for example we wouldn't we wouldn't
scale as a company because it there
wouldn't be enough content so very very
early on we actually started working
with television stations around China as
well as production companies to
syndicate content very very early on and
before even who was founded for example
and six years six years ago in 2009 both
Yoko and two though actually started
building or developing and producing
original
before was popular for Netflix and house
of cards and the reason behind that is
really the the fact that we really think
what we call web native content which
means content is targeted towards the
web audience has a bigger market
opportunity in China than it is in
developed country and let me explain why
in the u.s. here internet penetration is
very high so in other words HBO and
Netflix or ABC PS that demography at the
demographic they cover is actually
highly similar in China broadcast TV
also serves from five to seventy five
but the internet but our penetration is
lower and it's highly concentrated used
to be at the PC age about eighteen to
thirty five-year-old now we've entered
into mobile internet probably around 15
to 45 but still a narrower demographic
so we felt there was a clear market
opportunity where you can develop
content that's targeted towards audience
where the TV audience or the content
design for TV has to address to a much
more mainstream and broader audience
another very significant difference for
us was actually we develop our own
back-end technology ourselves I I recall
YouTube used to outsource to limelight
or Akamai and we started actually from
day one actually rolling out our own
video content delivery network to this
day we still continue to build our own
back-end as well as we operate that
back-end and I think YouTube really
after they were caught by Google they
started taking these operations in-house
so as well I was describing because of
the market differences in China a lot of
innovation was actually I would say
imposed a force because we have to adapt
to these market conditions so that's a
really important part of how we think
about our product model and how we think
about a business model now I mentioned
original content so you know a lot of
people when they think about original
content is so what do people in the
internet do in terms of online video so
this is a hit show that we've done
we started we're in our second season as
is caught on the road this is a couple
you see here they met in high school
about 20 years ago and they started
their own company together and everybody
knows tofu I mean these guys invented a
machine that made tofu and made it lots
of riches and and a lot of people may
may or may not know there was a huge
earthquake in Sichuan in the
southwestern part of China a couple
years ago and they decided to go help
and when they decided to help they saw
how much how short life is
and really we think about how they think
about how to lead the rest of their
lives they went back to Beijing they
decided to sell their company and then
they started going on the road traveling
around the world and they went to in the
first season they went to some kind of
really interesting places for example
Chernobyl do people remember Nobel where
the nuclear plant exploded Somalia Black
Hawk Down what you know it's clearly a
very very dangerous kind of environment
and live volcano and the fella we call
260 because they used to weigh - so 270
270 abide sheet and basically promised
his then-girlfriend down home
many years ago that she would get a
really momentous wedding so in the last
few episodes in the first season he
proposed in North Pole and in the second
season we started basically with a bolt
from China to North America South
America and ended up in Antarctica where
they got married about a month and a
half ago in the South Pole with us doing
a live broadcast from Beijing where we
invited their mothers at the ceremony to
actually witness that the whole whole
ceremony itself so without further ado
maybe hopefully this works
a little bit hard to offer cheap to
Chidori
we'll make sure what a huge number being
higher welding and enhancing soil camera
oh boy you enjoy your show Vionnet can't
even donate for adam BM i hope you know
there are being for him for some time
well Sonny children you know nothing
else when I'm it's already on this jog
and walk and run the whole what you
could see though what did you show the
500 children doing your shoulder I
didn't found a she's an actually toddler
neighbor and she you know what sure go
WOW gave me three young for me
Johnson you down from the future in
function vehicle young on video with
over 20,000 on show me enjoys a charcoal
it's a game you know why generation ran
head-on Angie Nam the holy
Oh
71 men should sell fun with you now it's
all about me
and I don't want thanks
oh man
so I was having breakfast with the
founder of GoPro nickk nickk women
actually just a couple of days ago and
we what we're gonna do
who is probably going to set up a dozen
GoPros on that boat they're on the way
right now to to South Africa and then to
Brazil for the World Cup so this is has
not ended I mean this is will go on and
so this is just give you a kind of a
free version or a taste of what kind of
original content we're producing and
besides these kinds of what they call it
real reality series or a documentary we
also do micro movies we do web series we
actually also do animation entertainment
of our eye shows a whole myriad of
different kind of entertainment and so
when we think about Yoko and pseudo so
it's not really easy right I mean it's
at least it's a combination of Netflix
or YouTube and actually things that are
actually quite different even with this
models but what we know is when we come
to the US especially when we talk to the
financial committee this these are
easier to understand but what we're
trying to say here is we're starting to
see opportunities that are actually
quite different because of the market
factors and market hurdles I so I want
to elaborate on that a little bit more
and in China this is a market which is
on the fortune side there are no
incumbents
so to give video as an example we're
dealing with an environment where
there's no Comcast
there's no HBO and there's no TiVo and
so the fact that when we talk to our
Netflix as well as our Hulu YouTube
counterpart in this way the envious
because oh wow I mean you can actually
get content so early on I remember
talking to Reid and Ted about Netflix is
like well HBO locked up the window
there's a DVD a window and there's the
HBO window we don't get stuff till you
know six months or sometimes three years
after one that's why they had to go to
the original
content because they getting really old
library content whereas Chinese intent
users actually quite lucky they come to
Yoko into the doll they can watch a lot
of these TV series the day after and
movies on a paid basis we can usually
get it about a month out there it's in
the theaters
so no incumbents actually gives us a
bigger opportunity also market
fragmentation is another market
difference that dries that's very
different television here you've got
basically four broadcast stations six
companies in Hollywood and Burbank that
controls most of the content here in the
US in China with an environment where
there are hundreds of television
stations imagine a world where
nationwide there's about a dozen
channels each province and this 26 of
them have one satellite television each
province have multiple stations and
cities have their stations
so I said California has a dozen station
u.s. has another dozen station San
Francisco has another dozen station and
by the way first know who has to write
and so that's the market fragmentation
whether it's distribution on the
production side that creates an
opportunity for us to syndicate the way
that we'd be able to pass like I said
UGC we don't have as big as the
opportunity as you achieve when it first
got started and we've done a lot of
things to really encourage content like
the ones that we've seen but we have to
mark an opportunity to syndicate content
much more aggressively and with
dedicating globally not just in mainland
China Hong Kong Taiwan Japan Korea US
and Europe and that brings global
content to the Chinese Internet audience
and really changed the way that they
think about the world now of course
there are also a lot of negative
elements in the China market that we
also have to battle with and for us the
most market one its piracy you used to
be payment was also a very big
bottleneck for us because credit cards
not prevalent as is in the US but now
with mobile Internet payment gateways
like Ally pay
or widget payment those have actually
made the mobile screen a very very
accessible device for our subscription
and transaction video on-demand services
but piracy continues your problem when
you look at how we work with actually
the leading film companies here in
Hollywood as well as the leading film
companies in China last year Jochen todo
along with other video websites work
with these mpa as well as the domestic
film companies to really sue by the
video as well as Kevon and these
platforms that have a lot of piracy that
continues to plague the industry and
that's an area that we will continue to
to have to work against but we believe
especially if you've read the news
recently there's been a big crackdown on
inappropriate content as well as a
pirated content in China recently and we
believe the new administration led by CD
Ming and Lee kichan really is paying
serious attention to these issues and
when you look in the Internet I think
we're entering into really a new age in
terms of how people are thinking about
content so both opportunities and
hurdles is how I would like to kind of
summarize okay so that was really that
should we say the second you know big
phase now now we're really starting from
last year in 1 3 and 1/4 really
abandoned in multi-screen internet age
and and here the GSB and if you talk to
a lot of both
internet companies and offline companies
I think people will actually see these
few years that we're in right now to be
a very momentous period and it's a
period where there's tremendous change
there's a period of tremendous paranoia
with all offline companies where a lot
of companies are feeling threatened or
converged by really what's happening in
internet trends and this actually has
this pose and cons which also talk about
so we've entered a multi-screen internet
age and in China
really progressing to the the third
phase is that you are really seeing a
lot of trends converging and happening
at the same time and where I think
different companies as we meet in a lot
of the conference's is we're learning
from each other
is from a copy to China to having things
happening simultaneously to really an
age where companies are learning from
each other across the world and Chinese
companies are creating what we call made
in China innovation in many ways to to
drive that and as we enter this new age
and the really the crux of that and I'm
not you know telling you anything new
here is Mobile is changing everything an
essence for us in terms of video that
also means that with video with the
mobile screen it's with you all the time
and really goes back to the one verged
vision because we back in 2005-2006 we
said okay styling from the PC screen all
this is going to converge into
multi-screen well and with the mobile
changes everything in the sense that
it's with you all the time with the PC
that's not the case and actually also
impacts commerce because at the end of
the day this is the screen that's with
you that's close to your purchase
location and occasion and and when you
actually see visual images that can
impact not just the content you consume
of what you decide to do what you did
start to eat or what you decide to
consume or what you decide to buy as
these trends converge we see a
tremendous amount of opportunities in
the US and China around the world and
what has is accelerated is I think one
three people starting at talk about Oh -
Oh online to offline but I'll actually
prefer to call it online + offline
really the convergence of online and
offline a month ago I hosted a group of
venture capitalists who actually visited
China went to 20 different companies and
by design we
we were the last visit they came to
office and said an ass bill basically
it's like okay after having seen 20
companies in China what are some summary
thoughts and one of the things that
really struck me was that he said well
you know we heard we hear all these
things about Oh 200 in the US but we
seen that in China
this whole Oh 200 plus Oh it's actually
happening faster in China than the rest
of the world and when he said that I
kind of gave him that hypothesis so why
could that be the case and I actually
goes back to my original thesis of how
market conditions drives these kinds of
changes of innovation and that's really
because if you look at offline companies
here the u.s. they're private
they're already in a very competitive
environment I was in a technology
conference here in the US in March in
Arizona and Sol Brian Roberts from
Comcast showing the Xfinity platform and
while you think all comcast is the
old-school company which is an incumbent
when you look at Xfinity platform while
I still don't believe his vision of the
remote control but the voice recognition
all those user interface and user
experience I think was pretty good but
in in China the same offline companies
whether you're talking about financial
services healthcare education
entertainment media and so forth and so
forth
they are highly regulated in the
insulated environment and most of these
companies are stayed on whereas the
Chinese Internet companies have been
fiercely competitive in a private market
now listed globally and as such a lot of
offline companies in China feel that
they're because of their market
conditions and the history they feel
even more surprised by all these changes
that's caused by the mobile and so
that's why you know my belief that the
online Plus offline trend is happening
faster because the offline world is so
much less ready for really these
convergence between the online and
offline worlds so on our space to give
you an example this whole o plus o
online plus
in terms of movies when we first started
out I guess in some ways we were like
Netflix in the sense that we have the
post theatre video on demand business
we're like YouTube in the sense that
we've been very involved in movie
marketing and distribution and at the
same time we're like I mentioned we've
also developed a lot of micro movies
that has actually generated a lot of
young and aspiring directors who are
actually making now big movies but
starting from last year because of these
changes on the mobile we're seeing that
a lot of offline companies are working
with us closer and closer where we we
really feel that we are actually
converging with the offline space for
example recently we work with Disney on
the Captain America Winter Soldier I
think I got that right and we actually
did a live broadcast of the premiere in
Beijing one where Scarlett Johansson and
some of the other stars of the the movie
was in Beijing doing the premiere and so
plus at the same time they were on our
show which is a hit show called star
talk where we have access to all the top
you know the director as well as all the
stars and which gets over 10 million
video views per day
I mean per episode for all that is real
really seeing ourselves working very
closely where we pick two three movies
of a month where we can actually impact
box-office offline at the same time last
year we started working with people may
remember the Crouching Tiger Hidden
Dragon movie the producer the fellow
called Bill Cohen friend of mine and we
actually could go produce a movie by
Andy Lau and witiwat which is the one of
the big actors in Hong Kong and we
actually could reduce a movie which
became the biggest hit for Andy in China
and this year actually we had a we're
gonna have a micro movie which was very
popular in China a few years ago called
boys that we again working with all vine
companies were called producing and that
micro movie is going to be a big screen
movie that's coming out later this year
so we've seen that these online offline
opportunities are real
coming together and the same kind of
things happening actually across all the
different genres whether it's TV series
or animation or music and performances
and so forth and so forth so kind of in
summary when we first started the
company in terms of the vision of
convergence into one a search fund and
then in 2006 after the diligence we said
okay you know we think that we've got to
build I would actually had a couple
business models and we decided to build
an online video website first and that's
how it started both vo good to know and
but as the mobile becomes more and more
important we don't no longer view
ourselves as the video website because
now after only two years our mobile
traffic actually exceeded our web-based
traffic like we were doing about twenty
five million daily video views second
quarter 2012 and now we're a stage we're
doing close to 400 million so the
acceleration of the mobile based traffic
is phenomenal where we're seeing a
mobile traffic our app traffic actually
larger than our old business which is a
website so our website is actually a
smaller business comparing to our app
business right now so as we move forward
as we see these offline opportunities
ahead of us at this point in time we
think that we're moving to become really
a multi-screen entertainment platform so
as the market opportunities emerges
we're really pushing the envelope and
thinking about how we view our company
so that's for for Yoko and to Don but
pulling back again thinking about having
seen these twenty years of Chinese
internet looking forward people may be
asking okay it's great 20 years so
what's next so what are the key trends
that we're seeing going forward so I
want to kind of give a couple of
highlights on my thoughts here what
happened here there should be another
three slides but if there isn't I can
memorize them
I think there are three trends I kind of
want to highlight to the group well
first of all I'll start with the us
friend of mine actually bought a Google
Chromebook I guess and then was
complaining to me how that it's not
possible to be on the Chromebook and new
Skype oh sky is owned by Microsoft oh I
can't use Apple iTunes Oh Google doesn't
like Apple right so the point I'm trying
to make is really internet started as an
open platform and in the US and it's
increasingly so happening in China as
well is moving to become a semi closed
system and that's actually problematic
from a user experience standpoint and
certainly something that we don't you
know believe and in China you probably
also read about the really kind of the
large size companies and a lot of people
may have read our strategic recent
strategic investment from Alibaba and so
which we announced actually last Monday
and actually that one of the reasons why
I can actually commit to coming here
until last week and so we're also seeing
the same situation like Google or Apple
or Microsoft or Facebook all these
companies in the valley kind of closing
themselves to each other and in China
what we want to prevent and it's also
starting to happen is like you know
these great companies Alibaba who really
started from kind of a b2b company which
actually you don't really see any global
example and launch c2c as well as
payment and b2c and hemo and has been
very successful or Tencent from instant
messaging our a.m. to become a very much
kind of a social gaming mobile and
Internet allagadda
platform and these platforms and these
companies are starting to feel that they
used to be very different businesses and
they're all converging and competing
with each other but even then I would
argue that we should really encourage
the whole intent to be more open and
that was the way that we thought about
strategic investment when we talked
these
companies one of the things that we
insisted on is will only take a minority
investment and will continue to open to
cooperate with other companies in the
ecosystem and as we think about how we
develop our own ecosystem
I will also want to think of it as a
very open way very much like the
standard way okay so that's point number
one - over the last 20 years and maybe
the exception of the last maybe two to
three years use most of the Chinese
Internet companies while they have gone
public around the world we've all been
very focused on the domestic market and
I think we are starting to see some of
the leading companies look overseas and
you will see looking forward decent
these Chinese and tech companies
starting to go global now of course I
mean golden global takes a completely
different skill set and what's
interesting is and we can talk a little
bit about actually US Internet companies
have had actually some success and some
failure stories when they come to China
and we when we when we actually talk
among the Chinese entrepreneurs like
okay when we look at the US or other
parts of the world let's think about you
know what which markets to enter as well
as whether we need a local partner so
what will be interesting to see is
whether the leading Chinese internet
companies were actually partner with a
lot of the leading international
internet companies and whether they
would become successful or not okay so I
think that's probably a second a very
important phenomenon I see the third is
actually going back to my whole point on
online Plus offline I don't think there
will ever be again any pure online
companies or pure offline companies
where all these convergence are
happening around us whether is
convergence across multiple screens
whether is convergence between online
offline whether it's convergence with us
Korea Japan China all these internet
markets around the world if in 20 years
of internet were you seeing all these
pockets of innovation that are starting
to learn from each other
I would like to if that's one point I
want to convey is all these innovation
and all these are converging and all
these things are all happening into an
environment where we see starting from 1
3 and 1/4 as we look in the next 10
years and next 20 years of Chinese
intent or global internet this is the
time this is the now period where we see
these things converging and we see even
more opportunities in the future and
looking back you know 20 years ago I was
sitting where you are and now I'm here
but a little bit more right here and
thinking about as you think about your
career as you think about the GSB change
lives change organizations change the
world and here we have an opportunity
well you see we're really in the
beginning of multi-screen understand
what kinds of things you can do in the
next 10 years the next 20 years and what
we can do as an industry in open
Internet to create more innovation and
more opportunities for the world thank
you very much
so how they're doing time I went a
little bit longer
hello this is some nice 20 years
Technium MBAs I can two questions the
first question you said right now online
piracy is their own vagina I'm just
wondering technologically also for
coarser wise what can I change do you
see right now in China never mind you
solve this problem so this is
synchronous about the multiscreen
like entertainment you mentioned when
now like you are trying to build a
multi-screen platform so also I do some
research about March screens I said like
people always using the smartphone at
home some just wanna can use it'll be
more about subsidy what kind of strategy
or how to minimize screen to do like a
mobile app or including knows connecting
vacation or switching the action to
remote screen thank you
with first world piracy when we actually
at the in the last year we had a cross
industry initiatives monitored chinese
video websites as well as mpa as well as
the leading domestic movie companies
like ye or or like boehner and we've
actually had a fair amount of success
both the legal and the regulatory side
especially the consumer facing ones
which were mobile apps actually a lot of
the mobile apps that were asked to be
taken down as as they lost their
lawsuits but you're right from a
technology standpoint a lot of these
services have pulled it away to these
cloud-based like I want to say
BitTorrent p2p software or cloud base I
don't want say Dropbox but you know but
a little bit like that those kinds of
services where we still see piracy so it
will be a continuing
really exercise for us to keep working
with authorities and working with the
legal system to help them identify all
these pockets of piracy and really
driving to that so that's one and the
other one is actually a very good
question and when you think about my own
multi-screen actually Asia has actually
interesting opportunity because here
most people drive in in Asia most people
because they're very dense
most people take public transportation
so we're starting to see our user
basically on the mobile phone screen on
the subway and then wanting to go home
maybe 20 minutes into a show they want
to go home and have that experience
continue on their tablet or their big
screen the sole actually two three years
ago we started developing a lot of these
cloud-based services basically following
the user across screens so they're
literally going to the you know the same
point in time on the next screen and
after you finish the screen we're also
tracking what kind of content that users
watching across different screens at
different times because in the morning
you may be more interested in news news
bites and in the afternoon going back to
work so when people started watching TV
series and variety shows so that on the
way to work and going back to work
actually going back home actually people
watching different content and what kind
of things you recommend to them at
different times
also we've starting about two years ago
also started developing these technology
where the mobile form actually remote
controls that our screen and and all
these screens will actually start
interacting with each other imagine well
well you you know sitting on the couch
with a tablet and you're browsing
through content you click and it goes a
little bit like they'll play I guess but
how do you get your apps to really
interact with your big screen and very
similar to Netflix we actually develop
you know work with a lot of the Smart TV
as well as the set-top box manufacturers
in terms of because you know you'll come
to though with a other top brand so we
kind of the default solution for a lot
of the API is that a lot of these kind
of device manufacturers actually work
with us so I hope that addresses your
question
barring talk I'm actually I don't know
grad at Stanford I also have two
questions so the first one is that you
mentioned that there's a train that the
internet company gonna get together and
cooperate with each other in the next
few years right but it can be
problematic because you have the
potential to block any other startups to
enter the market so how do you solve
that problem and the second question is
that as we can see right now there's a
lot of international students from China
who have this education background and a
lot of us might probably go back to
China in a few years so to have any
advice for us and also how do you think
that our position in the work market
gonna be in the future and also how to
think if we go back and have become
entrepreneur in China do you have any
advice on that thank you very much okay
there's a good bad and ugly here okay
I'll say that that the tough part first
okay so what we seeing is as we move to
mobile and Stan you know initially a lot
of people in the entrepreneur as well as
a VC community think okay this is a new
age of moving from PC and mobile
internet there's going to be plenty full
of opportunities now while there still
are opportunities if you look really at
the top 10 and top 20 apps really in
China what do you find is that most of
them are actually from some of the top
companies in fact if you look at the top
say 10 PC Internet companies someone
actually been struggling moving to the
mobile and saying and I would say a
roughly half of them actually have made
it in the top 10 in terms of mobile ads
but when you look at the top 20 20 you
really don't see a lot of startup apps
and even the solid maps are heavily
invested by some of the big players so
that is unfortunately a reality as when
we started the PC internet there weren't
any incumbents right so but now with the
mobile instant you've got PC instant
incumbents that are leveraging their
their market power or their capabilities
to move to mobile internet now but the
fortunate thing is I think starting from
two years ago
we like to think we have a little bit to
do with that because of the merger
between York wanted of because before
that there really want a lot of ma
people don't like merges people don't
like acquisitions and and I remember
when I was a portal you know when I I
did you know three acquisitions while
there but they were like you know ten
million us or that and that was already
very unusual back then but now in the
last two years especially you starting
to see billion-dollar mergers and
investments and that's something that's
really changed in the last two years so
we used to be as Chinese entrepreneurs
are very envious of the Silicon Valley
okay now there's no way but IP Allah so
we got to make it to the IP alright
but now there's actually quite a healthy
M&A market now and so as a founder you
know I think going public is one way but
that's no longer another way so I think
that the with market changes as market
matures I think you have to take the
good with the bad
that's probably my my my kind of
synopsis of what's happening now I've
seen Amazon and even doing the same
thing and trees are you seeing more of
that in China tech companies getting
into that space and if so what what do
you think is driving that trend going on
with original content okay well I think
different companies moved in original
content for different ways like I
mentioned in the case on Netflix if you
talk to those guys it's like they always
struggle to pay lots of money to buy
kind of syndicated content but usually
in a very very late window so they
realize you know and the fees keep going
up it's not easy to negotiate well
Hollywood a bummer back because it's so
concentrated I'll talk about so they
started looking at math it's like okay
well you know it's going to be very hard
to be possible because every time I make
money they wrecked ramp up the phase
right and then still I want to get
overly overly windows and after three
years and five years it doesn't work as
you've probably so recently HBO signed a
deal with Amazon Prime right
and we talked to Jeff Baker's I mean
Netflix is that our rival right you know
it's like actually I understand Netflix
subscriber base actually exceeded that
of HBO this year in the u.s. so you
actually see those things happening but
I think what happens is that original
content helps these players get content
in a much early window as also
innovation like you know binge watching
or big data and all the stuff that
Netflix packages so early window more
cost-effective as well as help you
actually creates or innovation models
also branding I mean as HBO think about
HBO without the Sopranos or Sex in the
City or like games of Thrones and I
think for online copies also understand
what that means for a brand and so
that's why we'll also do a lot of
original content like that but for
Amazon and and I think Hulu is also
trying to do the same thing Microsoft I
think people appreciate and understand
that is that that's really a phase where
once you've got a distribution platform
of a certain scale then you have the
potential now potential to be able to
actually foster original content if you
don't have the reach you can spend a lot
of money and you don't get anywhere so
that's actually a very interesting
dynamic and while you think about the
business has to have the evolve at
different times doing different things